vampire chicken 63-minute standard
standard three minute okay mental note
I'm starting with less time and get out
of your five minute mentality right here
here we go okay II for for the win
okay French defense and let's go with
the winter water okay and that hmm let's
go here F for Knight f3 Bishop III Queen
d2 actually Knight a for in response to
Queen b6 I should have played that in
that earlier game so where is my Bishop
on it be
let's go Queen D - 22 - f - in fact
I'm gonna play g3 this is actually a bit
scary to do this because the night might
get the bright idea to land on c4 right
I do have to be cautious I'm with g3 I'm
saying okay I want my bishop on g2
but-but-but pop-pop-pop the c-4 square
is definitely weakened I'm gonna play
here just to reinforce d4 and I am in
position to play b3 to watch over the
c-4 square okay now what direction
should I go in I think I like this pawn
move let's develop here first
f5 I would love to get in with the
Knight f4 continuation maybe just even
upon sack okay I think I'm better now
because I have this pawn break in
successfully I wonder if this was
somehow a mouse slip maybe it was g6
that was meant to be played now this is
big trouble because of the light squares
take here now Knight f4 right away on
the pawn and at this point right here
King side castle my rook is contributing
and if my knight cannot be dislodged
from this square I think there's some
serious issues for black and I'm seeing
it be the case that it's going to be a
while before it could be dislodged
because I can connect my Knights night
g6 I'm going to do it right now night g6
if it's challenged with Knight here I
could follow up with the knight h4 no
need to do it right now though until it
is first challenged so in the meantime
let me even play over here looking to
play on both wings open up the B file I
think going with the apon is the best
way if I capture then there we go half
open
a file if this capture occurs then it's
going to be a wide open B file let me go
with this okay and actually let me just
make certain of nopon push in the night
getting here I don't want this square to
be made use of so what could I do to
make progress my dark square bishop
needs some help
where's my queen wanna be where I would
buy Queen wears a dream square for my
queen hmm well actually what's wrong
which is doubling rooks no I'm gonna do
this with the idea of Queen age three
Knight f4 I think it could be very
uncomfortable to defend this pawn what
gets done with that now okay keep still
think I keep that night right here maybe
I
yeah that's pretty smooth move right
there okay so let me take and put
pressure on that pond yeah it comes to
just in the nick of time I think our no
actually my Knights hit what am i doing
let's do this I guess my Knights long
gone but my queen is active and this
night is still homeless just kind of
hanging out there so maybe there was
something with getting my pawn up here
to secure my Knights position I probably
should have looked into that but I still
think this is advantageous even though
my bishop is kind of bad can I get it
over here hmm I think now the time now
is the time to double pressure on the
knight now that there's a disconnect
between the rooks I think if I maybe did
that a bit earlier there would be just
all the heavy pieces coming off the
board but these guys are not on the same
rank any more difficult to meet the rook
moves to these squares so let me retreat
to ask where that's going to be no y
retreat
I could take this safely actually now
let's come back 21 seconds pound push
Queen h4 and Bishop on f4 locks
everything probably get my other book
over here maybe my queen
could she swing over in this direction
I'm gonna try that actually
rook up check right here tripled up the
King can't run away now my queen is
sneaking in my bishop maybe even dark
square pin night I could have just taken
the night that would have been made
really close to it when I moved my queen
right there that should have been me
right here up there instead of the Queen
move I could take the knight I missed
that okay
good game that was interesting let's see
um I don't know
right here let's see I don't know about
my moves right here the the night going
back actually right here I don't know
about the g3 move but I just I think
this is a typical lift sometimes I think
there might be a queen f2 putting more
pressure on this pond forcing it to do
something but and this tension releasing
the tension I don't know about that like
how about just capture and then maybe
try and get your knight to this efore
square I wonder if that's uh I don't
know if you could be running with
something like that then you how there's
no tension in the center so now I'm
gonna be looking to play on the King
side and I don't know where blacks
should be going with their king you know
Queen side it's a little bit airy these
puns are a little bit overextended and I
do have some play on the A or B file
with that starting with that e3 move and
right here I think playing g6 it may be
a better way to
do things as soon as I get this break
and I'm feeling pretty good
g6 maybe I didn't play it as well maybe
I'm h4 h5 is an idea clamping down on
this square I don't know my opponent did
well to neutralize that night though
black certainly identified where I have
a well placed pieces and it definitely
is the night in blacks territory right
here on g6 if there's if the knight is
able to sit here these rooks never get
to contest this F file that's the that's
one way to translate this Knights
position on g6 if he sticks around here
he's watching f8 if he's watching f8
you're Brooks can't do much on the F
file at least maybe it is best to
actually play King here and look for one
pair of rooks to come off the board if
I'm able to keep two on the board
there's I think well I think two rooks
is just too much for you to cope with
okay so I got pushed around a little bit
but we were both moving crazy at that
point no not very much stock going into
it
from then on so okay let me close out